ah
bienvenidos al mundo del futuro donde
los aviones de 180 puestos son
eléctricos y los aviones de carga
transportan mercancías hasta el corazón
de las ciudades este mundo donde la
electricidad reemplaza al queroseno
parece inalcanzable pero según algunos
fabricantes esta será nuestra realidad
dentro de 10 años
uno de ellos se encuentra en esta ciudad
de eslovenia la empresa pipistrela creó
un avión 100% eléctrico con dos puestos
es el primero en estar certificado por
la unión europea
es realmente silencioso no hace mucho
ruido es estable y como funciona con
electricidad no hay contaminación
el orgullo del piloto finalmente poder
volar sin emitir co2
pero al cabo de una hora es necesario
aterrizar para conectar el avión ford
church y cargarlo toma la misma cantidad
de tiempo que la duración del vuelo
tiene poca autonomía pero gracias a su
precio similar al de un avión
tradicional es un éxito comercial se
construyeron 40 aviones el año pasado y
se hará casi el doble este año los
motores eléctricos empiezan a reemplazar
los motores tradicionales
este es el motor tradicional de gasolina
es muy grande pesado y con el tiempo
muchas piezas deben ser reemplazadas
cuando lo comparamos con el motor
eléctrico este es mucho más pequeño
liviano y tiene muchas menos piezas que
reemplazar faltarles
darnos dos partes tu piel exprés
un motor y una batería liviana serán una
de las claves del éxito y la empresa no
piensa detenerse ahí se destaca la
maqueta de un taxi volador eléctrico de
cinco puestos para 2025 y en tan sólo
ocho años habrá un avión de 19 puestos
con la suficiente autonomía para poder
cruzar francia en un solo trayecto está
llegando entonces la hora del avión
eléctrico
easyjet se asoció con una empresa
estadounidense para producir este avión
de 186 puestos gracias a dos motores
nuevos
el objetivo verlo volar en tan solo 10
años
y la tecnología de las baterías avanza
rápido pero es muy difícil alimentar un
avión como este que tengo detrás solo
con motores eléctricos tal vez tengamos
una etapa intermedia con aviones
híbridos así como existen carros
híbridos con una parte de queroseno y
una parte de energía independiente
pero para que los aviones eléctricos
sean realmente independientes será
necesario fabricar baterías que no
contaminen y producir la suficiente
cantidad de energía renovable para
alimentar esos millones de aviones
algunos pioneros están abriendo el paso
pero el tránsito hacia ese nuevo mundo
todavía es lento